It's something I want to tell you about
the stress and how we have to look at
stress.
Okay.
And I think it's an important thing
because many people have told me from my
lectures is the one thing they remember.
Okay.
I was it in a dentist office and looked
at an article that said,
how do lobsters grow?
I don't care how lobsters grow,
but I was interested.
And it points out that a students,
a soft,
mushy animal that lives inside of the
rigid shell,
that rigid shell does not expand.
Well.
How can the lobster grow?
Well,
as the lobster grows,
that shell becomes very confining and
the kind of the lobster feels itself
under pressure and uncomfortable.
It goes under a rock formation to
protect itself from predatory fish casts
off Michelle and produces a new one.
Well,
eventually that Shell becomes very
uncomfortable as it grows in the red
back under the rocks and the lobster
repeats this numerous times.
The stimulus for the lobster to be able
to grow is that it feels uncomfortable
right now.
If lobsters had doctors,
they would never grow.
Because as soon as the lobster feels
uncomfortable,
goes to the doctor,
gets a valium,
gets a percocet,
feels fine,
never kept off his shell.
So I think that we have to realize is
that we have to realize that times of
stress are also times that are signals
for growth.
And if we use adversity properly,
we can grow through adversity.